folks was this an expensive mistake or
is it a warranty issue so that's kind of
the scenario that we're looking at here
and this is something that is an
unfortunate situation renders the
three-point hitch on your tractor
useless until you do something about it
and so customers submitted this question
to me and I I'd seen this happen
randomly over the years not too often
but you see it come up and that's going
to be where your top link on your three
point connects right back to the kind of
the casting or the housing on the
transaxle up above there so this
gentleman snapped off one of those ears
that hold on the top link
get a 2021 3E series tractor it was
still under
kind of that bumper to bumper warranty
in the two-year range s's John Deere
dealer if it would be covered and they
told him that physical damage is not
covered and so when he mentioned that
back to me that prompted my follow-up
question of well how are you using it
when the damage occurred so for me this
comes down to a use versus abuse kind of
scenario you know are you just using the
tractor like you normally would or are
you pushing it Beyond its limits maybe
going against something directly called
out in the manual or potentially is it a
casting defect something that should be
a you know a manufacturer's defect that
should be covered under warranty it
could be difficult to prove though guys
I need to have a serious conversation
for just a second but
most of you don't like or subscribe my
videos and I really don't know why
so if you do me a favor this holiday
season and uh
hit that Thumbs Up Button subscribe
I'd really appreciate it so I asked him
to explain what happened when the damage
occurred and he had a brush hog on the
back of his tractor and he was backing
up and uh he hit something he shouldn't
have apparently maybe going too fast
hard to say that's a subjective
scenario I suppose but it must have
jammed up you know just imagine the
snowblower just kind of jamming up into
the tractor and maybe twisting a bit I
don't really don't know how so thinking
about that that had to be a really
significant Force you know a snow blower
here is a is a rigid hunk of Steel
overall you know the the brush Hogs
actually have a little give those those
top arms they kind of give a little bit
and you can almost kind of wrinkle them
up a bit because if you're going
um in ditches kind of up and down there
it has some flex and so to really Ram
that into something so hard that it
overcame that and then still had enough
Force
to break off one of these ears
I don't know man I mean you got to be
out of control I feel like to have that
happen speaking of top links we just got
this cool new easy wheel haven't even
got it installed yet but this goes right
onto
your Top Lane kind of like a poor man's
hydraulic top link it's just an easy
handy way to do this we made we showed
some homemade versions of this before
but it's a discount Club member you buy
directly from them makes it easy to
spend that top link around for
adjustments or to hook up to an
attachment in fact we already got
feedback from a customer Mr Connor
already got his install on his tractor
says he loves it so so far so good now
the easy wheel is a discount Club member
use code GWT to save five percent off
your order now you think about a tool
that actually John Deere sells a box
blade among everybody else but you can
you can push backwards with your box
blade and kind of push things up and out
of the way wherever you want to go it's
well within the the limits of the
tractor to do so and so I think that
presents a scary situation that
fortunately not a lot of folks have gone
through but
he was quoted thirty four hundred
dollars to have that top housing
replaced which is just an insane amount
of money and now I think a better
alternative to at least investigate
first is if you can find somebody who
can potentially weld that back together
I would think for
10 of the cost of a thirty four hundred
dollar housing that you could maybe find
some in your area even if you had to
rent a trailer and everything else pay a
bunch extra labor just to get it over
there to them
I think that's worth investigating that
approach over buying a brand new casting
well I should back up because there is a
potential for this to be aluminum but I
I think at least that the section that
sits on top of the main transaxle is
cast either way it takes a special
welder to be able to have the the skill
set to weld cast iron or aluminum so
really this is a PSA to kind of dive
into your tractor manufacturer's
warranty and figure out what is covered
what isn't covered
and then that that kind of guides you
maybe on how you treat your tractor and
if you are going to be backing up or
perhaps using certain attachments that
could cause more stress in that area you
now know ahead of time and how to maybe
take it a little bit easier and again
this is such a random occurrence and I
started doing a little looking up to see
who else has had this issue and if I
could find it on any Forum threads
there's a couple on Green Tractor talk
on 2 Series and three series I think I
don't maybe a one series as well
a couple of potential items that could
cause that kind of an issue you
mentioned the post hole digger
which seems like you'd have to do a heck
of a lot of heck of a number to get that
to happen and then a stump grinder
that's a direct amount with all the
sideways force that that like the bomb
light 1p 24 is putting on there
potentially something like that not that
either one of those were directly
related but really just a couple of
potential attachments that could cause
this kind of damage folks I want to take
just a second to tell you about our
Channel sponsor rim guard they are a
liquid ballast solution they line up
with exactly what we do here on Good
Works which is talking about tractors
and tractor safety we see it as simple
as this if you own a tractor you need
rim guard in fact some attractors
include rim guard as standard out of the
factory liquid ballast is simply weight
all right and this weight hides inside
your tires it stays there all the time
it's a safety concern because tractors
are almost always too light and too
Tippy out of the factory the number one
attachment used by every tractor owner
is their front end loader so when you
pick up something heavy on the front end
your back end wants to pick up off the
ground rim guard liquid ballast helps
keep your back end planted to the ground
but beyond and safety is going to help
maintain traction because if those rear
tires those power driving tires are on
the ground you have traction to go where
you need to and you're going to operate
more efficiently because if those rear
tires aren't on the ground you're not
going to pick up as much as you need to
or take it where you need to go rim
guard is all natural that means it's
safe it is the heaviest per gallon
all-natural product on the market it's
not going to freeze it's not going to
corrode and it's available at over a
thousand dealers Nationwide to find a
dealer visit rimguardsolutions.com to
make your tractors safer today now there
are some tractor models out there and I
don't really know them off the cuff and
you guys can can leave comments down
below too so if you're if you're
shopping for a tractor haven't bought
one yet maybe this is a consideration to
take into account but there's certain
what do we want to call this a maybe a
top link
bracket or something but there's certain
models out there that have that bolted
on so if you did break it off you can
just simply buy a new small section and
bolt it back on unlike a lot of the
other models that you have to replace a
huge chunk of the housing and take a
whole bunch of stuff apart it's a really
big Endeavor a totally different story
so I'd be curious to know which of you
have maybe something that is bolted onto
the top versus a kind of a cast and a
whole one piece Contraption there
curious what models do and what models
don't so that's going to do it for us
today folks now if you own a tractor
then you probably need some tractor
attachments and we'd love to help you
out go to goodworkstrractors.com we sell
and ship all over the country every day
of the week 75 percent of you watching
are not subscribed yet what are you
waiting for it's completely free hit
that button down below and we do sell
merchandise as well you can get that
right from our website it's going to be
made to order we do not profit off this
at all we donate all the profits to
charity Christmas is coming up so it
could be good good ideas there too I
want to thank you for taking time out of
your day to stop by and until next time
stay safe we'll see you soon
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]